e aí galera que assisti no canal tudo
bem com vocês o meu está tudo bem porque
eu estou de férias mas eu sempre estou
de férias não é amiguinho está porque
porque um estudo de férias é um negócio
muito legal é que algumas pessoas é bem
legal e 6a que tem jeito que eu dei
férias principalmente gente que tem um
pequeno e que o pai ea mãe trabalha de
dia o que a pessoa não falar nada porque
tem ficar em casa cuidando do meu irmão
pequeno ou se for fazer alguma coisa tem
que fazer o que levar o cãozinho meu
irmão pequeno aí eu posso conversar com
meus amigos porque está aqui meu irmão
pequeno a pessoa não pode tomar umas e
aqui o meu irmão pequeno não pode fumar
maconha já dão chackras fumar cocaína e
fumar droga porque tá aqui o meu irmão
pequeno pode acabar lei para 180 por ora
bêbado embriagado porque tá aqui o meu
irmão porque gente como e quem tem um
pequeno em graça afirmou hipótese cinco
anos mas que ele vai completar 27 e não
completa 10 para ser cuidado também tem
gente que morre de festa que a mãe ea
mãe passa o dia fora de casa e quando
chegar a casca tudo pronto ainda pode
ficar em casa ea mãe fica mandando fazer
eco tem gente que é mãe sabe que a
inflação é quando eu voltar se essa
pedro que ferro um brinco tá toda hora
eu peço do caminho você só se planta uma
bomba eu vou lavar a mãe tá bom melhor
do ranking fez tanta coisa assim o
chamou me para deixar rolar é a mãe
saiba se eu falo que não só não mandei
está só falando de coxim lá que minuto
quando a hoje eu postava bem como
chegando à rua para cozinha é capaz de
correr pega a rússia deve reiniciar o
empate não eu já tava já está até mesmo
lavagem agora está começando e nas
férias a mãe falta em um táxi na
argentina lula está em tanta coisa caso
acho engraçado que pode fazer tudo de
forma impressa caso como existe uma
manhã com a minha filha falou que ela
vem pois a casa já varre e foi falar meu
carro a mãe se ela tem carro pois quando
eu tiver palavra
bomba limpa o mármore da janela eu já
nem penha bairro a minha cama agarrou
nené um mês sua cama troquei à costa o
que é assunto que eu vir outro feitos a
comandar linfática roteiro da casa já
tirei mantenham o governo acatará
aparece na primeira hora ligou banho e
já limpei e um cachorro e um cachorro
achou não banho no cachorro não gravou
da mesma não faz nada é de graça
ghaffar nada nessa casa encarnada
taxista empregado que querem fazer a
entrega da faixa eu sou brega 80
empregados recebam qualquer dia eu vou
sumir quando há qualquer coisa de phedra
que a pessoa passe esse ano e as férias
é a melhor do mundo eu vou fazer
escalada eu vou fazer alpinismo eu vou
te falar eu vou jogar pólo aquático não
coloque um banco em são roque
este ano se piloto de falam até que a
pessoa faça a historinha dorme mandou um
pouco no f dormir nas férias de verão
também dá um pio xii quando acordar já
perdi o natal ano novo e reis a inferno
a gente vai pra cá da globo o agente
advogado um primo e um muito a casa da
avó o que você pensa assim não próximo
ano eu vou entrar com um chip eu vou
tentar estar a deitar rasgado pintado de
hashtag vem monstro feira vou fazer a
dieta do ano até a casa da avó em tóquio
a gente com medo que ele volte mais um
planeta e você pode passar pode passar
calor você pode passar frio você pode
passar tudo que você possa não pode
passar fome se você quiser com fome não
tiver dinheiro para colocar comida avó
vem da sua roupa pra comprar com ele pra
você nasceu dormir na casa da minha avó
o acordo com ela quer botar com ele
quando minha boca é incrível e quando
você vai para casa um prémio muito graça
eu acho engraçado que você vai colocar
num bingo você dorme num colchonete no
chão seu primeiro passo a cada você tem
que sair da sua cama deixar seu nome na
cama você dormir no chão x muito graças
incrível e sempre um princípio a garagem
o primeiro preço é não domina se encaixa
no que tanto x de atenas até toco é um
ato na capa de um atrás no placar a tua
alma na toca mal nas festas que recebeu
os amigos de infância e as amigas antigo
quem sabe você brincar o rio de janeiro
vai focar os parentes para que você não
via há muito tempo e você fica feliz que
você tá com as pessoas que você gosta é
isso que é bom é o que você comentasse
aqui embaixo que você mais gosta na
série se não tiver gostar do vi que você
clica em gostei aqui no youtube se você
tiver o facebook aquela velha curtir a
ajudar mais no twitter que ele vai ter
no estado ela continua na foto vai
ajeitar se inscreve no canal para não
perder um vídeo noel é nóis banheiro em
branco
eu também vou pra casa o time romano